Wow you don't you don't seem like an
only child I know what a guess you're
just so good about sharing food I have
to get my niece something for her
birthday she's an only child I can't get
her a board game right who's she gonna
play with that explains why you have
such an active imagination
you must love being alone you must love
being around people your parents must
have treated you like the center of the
universe was it hard making friends I
bet you had a lot imaginary friends oh
you're an only child that makes a lot of
sense you must be really close with your
parents like your best friends right
didn't you wish you had a sibling
growing up why didn't your parents want
any more kids or oh is that too personal
you're one of the good ones what's wrong
with your parents
or is that too personal you're so lucky
you never had to share I wish I was an
only child
you're not even self-centered real only
you're gonna have to take care of your
parents all by yourself when you get
older that's gonna be really tough I bet
I've to yourself a lot you just seem so
well-adjusted oh but at least you get
all the best gifts at Christmastime
right
only children are the devil's children
it's true though
[Music]